hey guys how are you a happy 2014 this
is actually the first video that I'm
shooting in 2014 for this channel and
there's no better way to start off this
year than with one of my most favorite
events of the year Christmas is exciting
but the Consumer Electronics Show in
Vegas is by far the most amazing thing
that you will ever experience it's
pretty much this massive convention
center that is just full of electronics
that you won't actually be able to
purchase or that may never even come out
for years and years and years and years
just kind of depressing because you're
seeing all this really cool technology
oh this awesome stuff and you can't even
buy it now in previous years at CES
always the big hot topic is TVs bigger
smarter flatter I'm so sick of
televisions I can't even stand it for me
I am most looking forward to all of the
mobile technology anything that you can
take with you that can make your life
easier connected homes I have been so
obsessed with all of these applications
that I can use to control my house from
security systems to lighting to even the
nest which I feel like has kind of
broadened everyone's knowledge of what a
connected home can be like anyway this
video I just wanted to show you how I'm
going to organize all the crap that I'm
going to be taking with me to start off
the traveling part is the most difficult
because you gotta put all the stuff in
something and make it easy once you get
to the airport to just put it in all of
the bin so TSA don't start feeling you
up they usually do it anyway this
backpack I absolutely love because when
you travel you can only carry on two
bags well I put bags inside of bags to
make it look like I've only got two this
suitcase is what I usually put
everything into cameras a tripod all the
things so this is a little bag that I
usually use to put all of my gaming
stuff in but I'm not gonna be traveling
with my xbox this time I'll have a
little extra space this is my latest
purchase and I'm so pumped about it I
got this CBS it's actually a toiletry
bag but it fits everything that I need
perfectly so in this side we got my
GoPro this is an AC converter so
cars so I'll have a plug not only am I
going to see yes but I'm also going to
be doing another Sasquatch hunt so I'm
gonna need this for the car
a simple LED light this little tripod
that I can use for my cell phone
wireless mouse extra plugs so what I'm
going to be using for vlogging is my
GoPro I've got the extra little battery
pack on so that will pretty much a
double my battery life I'll mostly be
using this camera though because it has
really good zoom so I'll be able to
actually take a lot of cool photos and I
can connect this to Wi-Fi this is a
verizon Wi-Fi card so I'll be able to
have internet anywhere I am I'll also be
bringing this camera that I'm shooting
with which is the Canon 70d everything
has a little home and a compartment this
is the Canon x8n which I may end up even
using over the 70d because it does super
quick autofocus it does really easy zoom
and the onboard mic is pretty good so I
won't have to worry about using any
external microphones my passport I have
more extra batteries of course all of
the cords that I'm gonna need which are
mostly all USB because I really love
things that I can charge via USB you
need an extra charger that's just one
extra thing that you have to pack this
may look like a PS Vita but it's just a
PS Vita case this is that I have my
wireless microphones in intended es
because you have to get the street
passes so for the travel when I actually
get my laptop ready this will be going
in here when you get the TSA they're
like well you're really organized I'm
gonna grope you anyway perfect something
else that I would be carrying on the
show floor in my backpack not a Mac
surprisingly it's a Sony Vaio
Intel's two and one it's so freaking
sweet
it's basically you've got a tablet oh
hold on you have a keyboard I'm also so
excited because I will be doing a little
little special something with Intel
they're gonna be introducing this new
technology vloggers to make our lives so
much easier when it comes to making
videos and doing other sorts of really
cool things which I'm not sure if I'm
allowed to tell you yet but I think
that's happening on Monday so after
Monday I'll be able to show you guys and
I'll show you my onstage keynote
demonstration and it's gonna be so fun
but now
all the technology is I'm excited to
meet a bunch of you guys so if you
happen to be there please if you see me
do say hi we'll take a pic will tweet
will do whatever so make sure you say hi
and don't be a creep and like do a creep
tweet and say oh I just saw just see and
say hi just just a little friendly hi
I'm gonna go and finish packing
I don't even I'm gonna show you my
suitcase because honestly I'm packing
for two trips not only CES but another
Sasquatch hunt somewhere cold so excited
can't wait it's gonna be a really great
week so I love you guys and I will
hopefully see some of you in Vegas so
that's it I don't even know what I
talked about in this video